hi YouTube what is the economy going to
recover well actually no one really saw
the depth that we were going to plunge
to nobody saw the financial meltdown so
all those experts are telling you
exactly when it's fun to recover I think
have established our credentials well in
advance we know it's going to recover my
only comment to CEOs and the business
people alike is continue to invest in
new products new technology every time
you have a recession you try to save
your way out of it never works you have
to invest your way out of recession
economy will get better when we get new
products new technology new capability
to bring to the citizens of the world so
remember to keep the investment stream
going